that crop is always a crap shoot when
it's time to draft and it's even more of
one this year just like last year but
even more this year because last year
there was limited information in the
run-up to the draft but full information
from the prior football season this year
limited information from the prior
football season limited information in
the run-up to the draft no scouting
combine this year unlike last year it
really is even more of a shot in the
dark with some of these prospects and
you have to trust your scouting
department to
find a way to give you some basis to
believe that a guy is going to thrive at
the next level
when we know that for every guy there's
a ceiling somewhere between whatever he
has done in college in the pro football
hall of fame and it's impossible to
figure out where that ceiling is that is
the biggest challenge in scouting and
that is the thing that makes all the
time and effort and money that's spent
it at times feel meaningless because you
just don't know peter how that guy is
going to respond the first time he faces
nfl caliber competition is he going to
win or is it going to beat him and is he
just going to be relegated at best to
career backup status and that's the one
thing that will constantly elude these
scouts and these folks who think that
there's some magical formula out there
there isn't because you don't know what
that guy's gonna do until he gets
for lack of a better phrase hit in the
face by a grown man
sometimes you rise up to that challenge
and sometimes you don't and you don't
know
what that guy is going to do until he's
in that situation
well mike all you have to do is look at
the second pick in this draft look at
zach wilson the quarterback at brigham
young i've said it before on this show
one year ago today zach wilson was in a
three-man competition
for the starting quarterback job at byu
in a totally fractured off season
because byu
for many weeks could not do
the workouts with spring football at its
own facility because of covet so zach
wilson did not win this job last year
until august and
then you look at what zack wilson did
during the season
brigham young had an excellent schedule
last year going into the year but then
all the games got cancelled and the
athletic director tom holmoe had to
invent
a new schedule out of whole cloth
so
instead of playing you know the upper
division one teams he's scrambling to to
get teams to play like troy
and and so
that is what happened and so now you've
got to make a judgment
on zack wilson he wins the job in august
he's the quarterback starting in
september against um a significantly
lesser
uh set of competition
and so now you have to make a judgment
if you're joe douglas
and you're uh
you're mike lefleur the offensive
coordinator of the jets and robert sala
you have to make this judgment based on
stuff that
you wish you could see more
you wish that you could hang out in your
facility
and put uh zach wilson up on the board
and interact with them and everything
you can't do it
and i'm not saying that zack wilson
isn't gonna make it i like zack wilson i
like him a lot but
there is just so many question marks and
he exemplifies
those question marks in this year's
draft
that schedule that byu played this year
at one point sims and i ran through it
and there was at least one school on
there that my reaction was
what the hell is that school i've never
heard of that school in my 55 years of
existence that's the kind of schedule
that byu had to slap together and that's
the conundrum that the jets face
although everything seems like the jets
are locked on to zach wilson there's
been no effort this week by the jets
publicly or privately to push back
against the idea that now that sam
darnold has been traded
zach wilson is the guy there was the
question this week posed to joe douglas
about
steve young the former byu quarterback
suggesting wilson is the guy and douglas
kind of joked about it and you can just
see peter the difference between the
general managers who are playing poker
and those who are in position to count
their chips
douglas has no reason to pretend that
his hand is anything other than what it
is because after trevor lawrence to the
jaguars and we'll talk about him in a
minute
douglas controls the board he doesn't
have to act like he may take someone
other than zach wilson and i know there
are people who think that
that
that the jets may not take zach wilson
but you've got to you've got to do
something to push back against the
growing notion in your fan base peter
that zach wilson isn't the guy if he
isn't the guy because folks are going to
be in for a shock
in 20 days
if the name is anything other than zach
wilson
here's the thing uh i think
you know i i what is that i just looked
up the brigham young schedule mike was
it north alabama was it texas san
antonio was it texas that one
it was texas san antonio utsa i saw utsa
and i was like what the hell is that is
that a bank somewhere
hey look i think
i think
the reason why
joe douglas and luke might i reported
whatever three weeks ago whenever that
trade was made that the 49ers had
uh checked with the jets at number two
uh and were told i believe in no
uncertain terms that we're not moving
this pick
i think here's how it went for the jets
this offseason mike
robert salah gets hired
and i believe he tells joe douglas some
words to this effect i like sam darnold
uh michael fleur my offensive
coordinator likes sam darnold and if you
want to keep them absolutely fine with
us
we're happy to go you know to go into
battle with with sam darnold
but they said okay look let's just study
all these guys
let's study what happens
during the off season
and and look at all the games of all the
quarterbacks and then make a decision
and they made their decision that
there was a quarterback worth taking it
to after trevor lawrence because they
assumed all along that jacksonville was
taking trevor lawrence and that
quarterback was zach wilson now i don't
know if inside that team it was
unanimous
but i do know that that is the guy uh
that clearly
uh is liked by most of the people inside
the jets including joe douglas
and so
no matter what and and i believe look i
think steve young wants to see zach
wilson go to the 49ers but you know
that's not going to happen
you know zach wilson is going to go to
the jets he's going to be picked number
two
and then the jets you know mike
yesterday a very little piece of news
jets are interested in brian hoyer as
their backup and
and i had this question and i'd love to
hear your thought
why not alex wilson alex smith why not
alex smith for the backup
and then i found out that alex smith's
price tag might be a little bit too uh
heavy to be a
tutor uh to zach wilson so i think
that's why zach wilson
is going to have brian hoyer or looks
likely to have brian hoyer as his uh put
your armor on the shoulder kid i'm
playing josh mccown
yeah i think that makes a ton of sense
and they're going to need someone like
that if they want to get zach wilson
ready to go right out of the gates week
one and another thing joe douglas said
and we've seen this dynamic play out
this year because there are no private
workouts everything is public at these
pro days multiple pro days for the
high-end quarterback so there are
multiple opportunities for coaches and
gm's to go watch them throw douglas said
you don't ever take a quarterback until
you stand next to him and watch him
throw a football or as in the case of
urban meyer hear the football come out
of his hands and that to me peter a week
or two ago when urban meyer didn't go to
the byu pro day it was two weeks ago the
days are really blending together and
they continue to do so but when meyer
didn't go
that to me
made it
inc
underlined highlighted trevor lawrence
one
and jets on the clock for zach wilson
and again it it just feels like that's
the way it's going and if they're going
in any other direction there will be
shock
on the cover and back page and
everywhere else of the new york tabloids
in three weeks because it's all setting
up zach wilson and their pr
sensibilities will be completely
off base if they don't do something
between now and then to make people
think it's someone else because
i'd be sh i'd be beyond shocked at this
point if it's not zach wilson i think we
can we can for as much as we can put
lawrence in inc at one we can put wilson
in ink it too
i think so too mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports